hi there steve kaufman here to talk
about language learning again
if you enjoy the videos please subscribe
and today i want to talk about the
importance of a variety when we learn
languages
learning languages is a long
range
endurance kind of sport but there are
times when we
sprint like when we're all of a sudden
required to speak in the language or to
understand something but a lot of the
time we're just
continuing to do what seems to be the
same thing over and over again we're
listening we're reading we've have maybe
conversations
so it's very important to have variety
i remember some years ago there was a
concept in terms of physical training
called the fart lake rum
don't get concerned here
fart in swedish means
speed
lick is to lay guys to play so you play
with speed so if you're out running you
don't want to just run at the same speed
the whole time even if you're running
for 5-10 kilometers it's very good to
have
bursts of
of sprints in there so you play with the
speed
the same is true in in language learning
i find so you have to vary
vary the content that you're listening
to
uh i always said for example when i used
to start in a new language i would buy
two or three different starter books
teach yourself
living language whatever to cover the
same ground
from different perspectives using
different materials
another thing is i've said and then i do
this myself is to vary you know the
difficult material with easier material
so recently in my greek for example
i started doing these newspaper articles
from
tovima
italia gr dot gr and these are difficult
and so i'm you know
linking like these articles have 30
new words i'm linking tons in fact my
statistics tell me that i'm linking i'm
i'm sort of saving 500 new items of
vocabulary every day
so i convert these from blue and yellow
and yet when i come across yellow ones
that in the meantime i've learned i'm
converting those into known words at the
rate of about 250 a day that's heavy
going and and i
you know i'm sort of working my way
through these texts understanding them
kind of but it's not sort of comfortable
now then i had a conversation with panos
an italki
greek tutor
and he made me aware of a resource
online uh
i should i'll put the link i think it's
neo hell like
n-e-o-h-e-l like new
hellenic or whatever
and in three days they're gonna have
this this
web page portal open up but even now
they have content on there for download
you know easy stuff beginner like a1a2
stuff for greek
so i downloaded that imported it into
link and of course it's quite easy so
i'm going through that quite quickly but
it's fun to do that and the great thing
about this uh learning material is that
it's kind of a starter book grammar book
but it's for people it's not specific to
the language of the learner so it's not
full of lots of explanation they can't
explain it in english german chinese
russian spanish whatever so it's just
greek
and so i of course i got it in lincoln
i'm going through it and it's just it's
wonderful and it's easy so it's it's
again it's varying the speed if you want
varying the the difficulty going over
some of the basic words basic patterns
that i've already
been through and of course forgotten
because whatever we learn we're kind of
slowly going to forget
uh
so it's very good and then i'm going to
go back to some
more difficult material so variety i
think is very important and when you go
back over easy material
for example i go back to some of my
early mini stores which i listen to
while doing the dishes
there's always vocabulary there that i
thought i had learned and which i no
longer remember what it means
so there's all kinds of benefits
to varying you know the difficult stuff
mining new material for new words
getting that sense that you're now
able to understand something of say
greek politics in fact i even listened
to a podcast that we have at link in our
library on greek politics which i
understood zero of the four and i'm now
starting to pick up some of it as a
result of having fought my way through
all these difficult texts saving words
and stuff but then i go back to this
very easy stuff
and i really enjoy it too
so
i'm saying you know getting to fluency
in a language is a long long road
uh in order to keep things fresh
introduce as much variety as you can
variety in terms of the level of the
material you're using variety in terms
of the sources you're using the kinds of
learning activities
keep it varied and that'll keep you
motivated but also as is the case with
this fart later on in running i think
it's good for the brain it's good
exercise to have that variety the
occasional sprint the occasional tough
slogging and then a period of smooth
gliding so
hope that's helpful
and remember if you enjoy this podcast
please subscribe
bye for now
[Music]
you